Welcome back, master and mistress!
Hello!
Hello, hello, hello, hello.
Hello to you, hello to you, hello to you, hello to you, hello to you, hello to you, hello to you, hello to you, hello to you!
And you, the viewer.
Ow.
And maybe the viewer as well.
Good morning!
Oh, me?
Yeah, you!
Minto Public Broadcasting.
Some people aren't at home.
Some people might be...
Some people are...
I was hoping to see a derp face like the thumbnail.
Oh, you know what?
I should have done Chibi Minto, huh?
No, the head would have been way too big.
She would have been...
She would have solved everything in two seconds.
The viewer at home, that's me!
What, you!
Thank you, Terry!
Thank you, Austin!
Thank you, Pentobopancho!
Thank you, guys!
My third bit stole me.
My Minto keychain was cute.
Glad you liked it.
Oh my gosh.
Good morning, Minto from Australia!
Australia!
G'day, mate.
Bloomin' Onion.
I wanna go to...
Outback Steakhouse.
You know, as funny as the first time I ever had the Bloomin' Onion...
at Outback Steakhouse was...
not in the United States of America, but in Japan.
I don't really go to Outback very much.
G'day, Minto.
G'day.
Oh gosh.
There was something that you would say that makes it sound like you're saying something...
with an Australian accent.
I can't remember.
Thank you for all the memberships, you guys.
Thank you, Jesse!
Thank you for the five gifts.
Welcome back!
Tentide.
I have to read the katakana.
KFBSkitwinner.
Oh my gosh.
Welcome back!
Sendo, welcome back.
Cuddlyzombie, welcome back.
Oracle, welcome back.
Takezo, welcome back.
JCTR, welcome back.
Redfun, welcome back.
Oh my gosh, there's so many.
DerpyPuggyFamily.
PugFamily, welcome back.
12AB, welcome back.
Daner, welcome back.
There's too many!
Oh, right.
That's right.
RiseUpLight.
Sounds like I'm saying razor blades.
Yeah, that's the one.
It's all green.
I'm on a plane with wifi.
Not quite strong enough for watching streams off to catch the VOD.
We call that the blue archive.
Have a safe flight, Tom!
CM Green, welcome back everybody.
Thank you so much.
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Oh gosh, I don't even know if I can go through all of those, but thank you.
A whole year.
I know my moves.
So yeah, welcome back.
Where have I been?
It's green.
Thank you!
I'm happy.
Pugbug, thank you for the gifted.
Thank you.
Today, we must expand our brains.
I have paper here.
For notes.
I saw people saying that you should have pen and paper for notes for this game.
Don't eat it.
Well, now that you're telling me not to...
But this game, Blueprints, actually for...
I've had this on my list for like weeks now.
I've been seeing it so much.
I get like some game recommendations through TikTok.
And so I've been seeing it a lot on there.
People being like this, I can't, I don't know if they're paid or not.
Paid advertising.
But people have been like, this is like indie game of the year.
It's so cool.
It's like so...
It's so...
It's unique.
It's really fun.
So I've been very interested.
So basically, it's like a puzzle roguelike.
But you're trying to get through this house.
And only through unlocking more stuff can you actually get further into the house.
So...
It's roguelike Myst.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
So...
Seems like maybe everybody's playthroughs will be a little bit different.
So if you like what you see too, you know, maybe try it out.
I don't know.
I don't know how it is.
I'm 16 hours in.
And it feels like I'm drowning in mystery.
No way.
Wow.
Love it.
You have a great day in stream.
Thank you.
I've loved this game a lot.
Played many hours myself.
Dozens left to go, I think.
I've got 10 pages full of handwriting notes at this point.
This game is insanely good.
Yeah.
I guess...
I guess there was like a...
What do you call?
Like a demo...
Out before this.
Because I heard some people already knew that this game was going to be really good.
And then the full game was released just a couple of days ago.
10 pages of home notes.
I'm into almost a year.
Awesome.
It's my birthday?
What?
Check.
What name do you want?
Aisling?
Which name do you want?
What?
Wow, bears!
Thank you for the 20!
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Thank you, thank you.
Where's the text for the tonal?
I will lurk to avoid spoilers.
I don't think we'll probably get so much into it.
But I understand.
Might be one...
I saw...
On Steam it says...
For those who like...
Outer Wilds.
So I'm like...
That's extremely promising.
Sorry, I just went to the Steam page.
That's like super...
Right?
That's like so...
The real puzzle here is how Minto is so cute.
Oh, sorry.
You know, I'll go over just by your first one.
For the birthday.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, holo aneki.
Happy birthday!
Your name reminded me of a video I saw...
Recently.
About...
Like the origin...
You know how when you go to a Japanese...
Vtuber...
And they say like...
Outer Wilds.
And...
If you ever wondered what that word came from...
It actually is like...
What was it?
The full word is like niki niki.
I believe.
And it was like...
It was...
It basically is like a different way...
It's like a...
I think it was...
Hold on.
Now I'm trying to remember.
I think it was like a gender neutral way of saying like...
Aniki or aneki.
Right?
And so...
Outer Wilds is like...
A shortened way of saying like...
You know...
The aniki.
So it's literally actually overseas bros.
How so many people translate it.
Which is so funny.
I never knew.
I never knew the origin.
Yeah, me neither.
This game was on my horizon for a long while.
I've been enjoying it so much.
I need more games like this in my life.
Outer Wilds type stuff.
Good luck.
Thanks, Zelo!
Let's...
Shall we get started then?
Yeah, now you guys...
Now...
You guys...
No.
Take that over.
Gaijin.
It's actually...
Like a...
It's actually like a nicer way of saying...
Gaikokujin.
So yeah.
Vivi says...
Kaigainiki neki.
Only one I've heard to do that.
But yeah.
So I think it's been shortened.
You know, Japanese always is being shortened.
So kaigainiki.
Shortened to...
Kaigainiki neki.
When you're addicted to me too.
Thank you.
Stay addicted.
I'm just kidding.
It's on my first paycheck.
Thank you.
You should've got something yummy with it.
You should've instead.
Hi.
Okay.
Alright.
Time to be brained.
Let's do this.
Don't go bomb.
Wow, Frank.
Welcome to membership of BigHandAnime.
Thank you for the 5 gifted.
In association with Raw Fury.
Thanks.
Welcome to membership.
So many membership things today.
I'm scared.
Sorry.
Don't jump at me like that, mister.
Codicils.
What's the P stand for?
Oh, it's just a jump scare.
Holy cannoli.
What oil mine did this man own?
Oh, is this
timed?
It's April.
Happy
birthday.
I'll say happy birthday once the curtain door blueprints.
It's so blue.
Is that...wait maybe the P stands for prince.
I wonder if you can like...
Speedrun this game.
Wait, what does it mean 50 in the...
I only have 49 steps left?
Wait, what do you mean by that?
Okay, hold on.
Let me sing happy birthday to you real quick, Daniel.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday dear Daniel.
Okay,
wait I'm not losing him anymore.
What's this?
Exhausting.
Searching the estate can be exhausting.
Each time you enter a room you lose it.
Also because I stepped outside and then stepped back inside.
When you no longer have any feet left, you will be too tired to continue searching the manor and must call it a day.
Open only in the event of my death.
Simon, welcome to Mount Holly.
You may not remember, but I have fond memories of your many visits here as a young boy.
And I hope these rooms provide you with as much amusement as it did in those last summer days.
By the time you read this, I will assume you are fully aware of my last wishes and all the details of the bequest.
Please do not mistake my intentions in giving you this challenge as a lack of confidence.
I assure you, nothing could have been further from my mind when I chose you as my heir.
With that said, there are a few ground rules of this commission covered in the fine print of my will that I feel I should bring to your attention.
No fee.
No tools or items may be brought onto the estate from the outside.
Tools and items found on the estate may not be taken off the estate.
You may not stay overnight.
Is this place haunted?
What do you mean I can't stay overnight?
I don't suspect that any of these stipulations should prove an impediment for someone as resourceful as yourself, but it is very important to me that you start fresh each morning and not rely on the successes of the previous day.
Oh my gosh, roguelike.
Sneaky goose.
One final word of advice.
Do not assume the rooms you find today will be the same rooms you find tomorrow.
Imagine you like, you live here and you're just like, I'm so tired.
It's been such a long day at work.
And you have to find your bedroom every day.
It's in like a different spot.
These grounds have provided me a home for the last half century and even I am uncertain of which room lies beyond any particular door.
How do you live like this?
Your grandmother used to say, don't go where the path leads.
Abandon the path and go where you want it to lead.
Wow, such a non-beady lifestyle.
It must be nice never having to have...
Never having to be like, what if you're in a hurry?
What if you have to find the bathroom?
What do you do?
This reminds me of Rose Red.
Actually, I feel like I've mentioned Rose Red quite often.
Rose Red was one of my favorite Stephen King's...
I never read it.
It was one of my favorite Stephen King's stories though.
So I reference it a lot.
Hi Minky, have fun playing Blueprints.
I heard it was really fun and puzzling.
Whoa, Delta, are you okay?
Whoa, whoa, whoa.
Maybe your cat went on the...
Are you okay?
Maybe your cat is on the keyboard.
How many times do you have to change the layout of this house, old man?
Game gives me the Forgotten City vibes.
Have fun, Minto.
Thanks, Chucky.
Hope you enjoy, Minto.
I got some stuff to do.
I'll be in and out.
Good luck with whatever you got doing.
I take it this game is the happy version of Stephen King's Rose Red.
Right?
With all my love and wishes, best of luck.
Herbert.
Is that an... Oh, shoot.
What is that?
That's not an S, is it?
Oh, yeah, it is.
Sinclair.
Okay, Gramps.
Oh, we have our Blueprints.
Fancy ass.
Don't scream.
You may access the Blueprint menu by pressing TAB.
This will serve as a useful map and inventory log during your adventure.
Oh, antechamber.
Where we can call... Oh, I'm on top of it.
There's call it a day.
Inventory.
Okay, neat.
Where should we go first?
Oh, do these mean anything?
Wow, she's hot.
Why'd they make the Queen look so beautiful?
I don't understand.
Benevolent House of Leaves.
It is...
Why does the clock look so weird?
Why is it like...
It almost...
It almost looks like it would be AI generated.
You know what I mean?
Why does it look like that?
It's not my birthday.
Happy not birthday to you.
What is this?
850.
Select a room to draft.
Whenever you enter this room...
Wait, what?
Wait, you get to choose what room you go into.
So we can get items or we can gain more feet.
My wisp tags.
No tags.
Let's try the bedroom.
Feet!
Plus 2 feet.
What do we have here?
Greetings from Redington.
Nothing on the back?
Anything in here?
Oh, mama.
She's got a pretty necklace.
Okay.
Also, I want to clarify.
I wasn't accusing this game of using AI art.
I was just saying that...
That the clock looked wonky.
I don't want people to think like...
Everybody will just say...
Someone will choose an AI art these days.
Or a Garmin.
A boudoir?
Hallway.
Storeroom.
I feel...
Oh wait, you have...
You must select one...
Okay, I can't close out of this.
So I have to choose something.
Too late.
Getting cancelled on Twitter.
Goodbye, my career.
Let's try this.
Because we need a key, no?
We can unlock this if we get a key.
From in here.
Little coin.
I have one coin.
Okay.
And key.
One key and a diamond.
Oh look, diamond.
I don't know what these are for yet, but...
And now we'll get two more feet.
Use.
Let's try it.
Oh!
Wow, so many doubloons and dice.
Ivory dice.
While drafting, you may use the dice to roll new floor plans.
Interesting.
Five doubloons.
Let's go.
Let's see.
Which one should we take?
Hmm...
Money and rerolls.
Yeah, so cool.
Thank you so much for the 20 gift and thank you!
I guess we'll just go this way.
So a corridor is always left unlocked.
Pantry.
Or den.
Maybe the corridor would be good.
Unless we're hungry for a snack.
Oh, the den gives you more doors.
Today is my birthday!
Metal Raccoon, happy birthday!
Happy birthday to you!
Happy birthday!
Also, you guys are so right.
We should look at the...
See, a corridor would make sense.
Or see, the den we wouldn't be able to do because the storeroom doesn't have any...
So corridor or pantry both make sense.
I think we'll go with the corridor then.
Happy birthday to my husband, Pen.
We share a birthday.
Oh my god!
There are so many birthdays today.
Why?
Happy birthday to you!
Happy birthday Pen and Soro so much!
That's so cute you guys share a birthday.
I think I'm going to go with the corridor.
This is our first run.
We can...
We can experiment.
What's in here?
I don't know what it means that it's never locked though.
Is this like... I can't tell if this game...
Like see, there are so many different types of paintings.
I can't tell if it's like a...
Atmospheric storytelling, like does this mean anything?
I don't know yet.
There's so much art.
Maybe we'll go with the hallway.
I don't know what the... What is the...
Are we trying to get to the antechamber?
Is that what the goal is?
Only one way... If it's not...
Significant...
Or rather if it is significant, there's just so much.
Doors in the west wing are more likely to be locked.
Interesting.
Thank you.
Doors in the west wing...
So like this side?
Anything over here?
Why is it... Why is it...
It's so quiet all of a sudden.
Plus 10!
It's a dead end!
We could do the... I think the den would be best.
Wait...
Lars, did you send superchat twice?
I think you accidentally did.
Or don't know, I mean.
The goal is to get to the antechamber.
The puzzles will give you aid towards the goals, but exploration is more important.
Understandable, understandable.
I want the 10 extra, but let's do the den.
I think it's more important to have a bunch of rooms, no?
What the hell is this?
Nahuel?
I hope I said that right!
Thank you so much for the 10 gifts!
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Really appreciate it.
Yummy.
And we have a trunk.
Oops, oops.
Here we go.
A trunk.
They really like clocks here.
Really?
They're a pretty big fan.
Of clocks.
Grandpa...
And locks.
Look, there's...
There's one, two, three, four...
Five, six, seven clocks in this room alone.
Damn, grandpa!
I think you need to hire an interior decorator.
Wait, this one is not moving anymore.
And it's also a different time.
Wait, it's...
10... wait.
Why is this one different?
Wait, they're all different.
Wait, no, these are... wait.
Am I wrong?
Wait, when did it become this time?
Wait, this one was still mov... wait.
I'm so confused.
Oh, now... no, nevermind, they are still...
Wow, they are actively moving.
Wait, so we started at 8.45 and now it's...
Not... it's nearly... wait.
Oh god, reading old clocks.
9.05.
Sorry, 10.05.
10.05, so it's been over an hour.
What is it?
What does this mean?
Okay, alright, let's go this way.
Analog, what did I say?
Gem requirement, I have that.
Drawing room might be good.
You may draw new floor plans while dra...
Or plus star...
Oh, old.
Am I wrong?
They like locks and clocks.
Are there socks somewhere in a box?
So mysterious.
Bochy the clock.
Bochy the lock.
Bochy the sock.
Bochy...
The glock.
I don't know what this means.
I'm sure this is, I guess, something else that you need to unlock things.
Let's try the drawing room, if we can get new...
What the hell?
Grandpa had one study.
Or, not one.
Just a...
Drawing floor plans.
Each time you click on a door, you will draw three floor plans, from which you must select one to draft.
However, there are some items and rooms that will allow you to redraw if you do not like the initial three options.
Yeah.
Oh my gosh, it's him!
How did you do that?
Did you draw yourself?
A self-portrait?
Before your death, grandpa?
Oh, wow!
What are these?
Why do they have these?
This is on the clock, too.
These, like, lines.
What is this, man?
Wait, I thought we'd be able to draw something.
Am I incorrect?
I thought we'd be able to create new types of rooms.
Nevermind.
Stride distance.
Yeah, scale chart.
The clock, remember?
I was wondering what it was on the clock, too.
Am I overthinking it?
I'm not sure.
I might be overthinking it.
Oh, you can reroll for free here, I guess.
Let's just... I'll just keep going up.
Oh, just kidding.
This way.
We have... Whoa!
Whenever you enter the chapel, lose a coin?
Hell no.
Wait, we can get ten...
We could get ten steps here and then go back to the...
To the hallway, I suppose, maybe.
Or I could re... Oh, wait, redraw.
Oh, I just get a free... Ah, I see.
Oh, it's a free one.
Okay.
Dang.
Maybe I should have done the bedroom.
I have to go back anyway.
Not much better.
I could re... I could do again.
I have two dice.
Items could be good.
True.
And it's not like...
Nothing ventured, nothing gained.
So true.
Whoa!
What is this?
Commissure?
What is that?
Breaker box?
Or spare room.
It's a breaker box too.
Oh, commissary.
I can't read.
These ones are mysterious.
Items for sale.
Oh, that's why!
It's a shop.
Shop.
Yeah, sounds like we can buy stuff with our coins.
But I feel like it's a waste to...
It just goes straight into a dead end, no?
I wanna... I'm curious what the breaker box is for.
So I'm gonna have that.
What do you do?
Key card entry system.
Uh-huh.
So I guess if there was a room that needed a key card...
Wait, toggling the... Wait, I should read the danger first.
Toggling of breaker switches may result in unexpected loss of floor pad functionality.
Please call DC power if you require assistance.
What's a VAC indicator?
I don't know, but green should...
Wait, why is one blue?
Purple!
Wait, what if I do...
Wait, did I do green already?
Just turned it back to blue.
A mystery.
Indeed.
I don't know what this means.
But yeah, maybe if a room needed a key card...
Maybe that's unlocked now.
And then I turn... The gymnasium?
I think it was the one that...
The dark room... Maybe I should turn that back off since it's a dark room.
DOSUKA!
Bye bye!
I hope you are having a good day too!
Yeah, we don't know what the VAC indicator means yet, so I guess we'll come back to this.
I'll just leave it on for now.
And there's more drawings in here!
So we gotta go back.
Let's go through here now.
Security?
Security gives us also an empty...
Like this one we can't use, but security.
Let's try it.
Oh, cutscene.
Oh my god.
I'm a twink.
What's that?
What are we recording?
Grandpa... Are we about to play Five Nights at Freddy's?
Twinkie?
No, I've never had one of those.
The twinkie.
Are they any good?
No?
They're alright?
Never had one.
Think of sugar, but fluff.
I don't know.
Maybe.
That one's kind of creepy.
Oh my god, thank goodness there's no one behind us.
That would be so scary.
It me!
Wait, the me on the monitor is not moving.
Oh, yes I am.
Let's see what we got here.
Is that a pool?
Indoor pool.
Hi, dog.
That looks important.
Life sucks right now, thank goodness for a window door.
I'm sorry.
I hope everything's okay.
Oh no, our drink is just...
It's TV static.
Okay, we got some other stuff over here.
Let's see what we got here.
Microwave...
TV static coffee.
Static juice.
What do you mean staff notice?
We have a password.
I don't know when I should start writing things down.
I'm nervous.
You do not fail to clock in and out.
Doobly.
Do not further notice that antechamber has been unlocked and access levers are no longer required to grant entry.
Keycard access security doors are more likely to appear in the higher ranks of the estate.
Likewise, as the redundant security measure normal doors in the estate will also be more likely to be locked as you progress north.
Okay, so keys are probably going to be important.
So what?
Now I have to pay people too?
No!
Not hot dog!
What does this button do?
Mega, thank you so much for the dono.
I can't crouch or do anything else, I just realized.
Oh!
Blue memos equals true.
Red memos... wait.
Equals lie unless written by hand.
Okay, I am going to write this down then.
Wait!
Remember we saw the red memo that said that the doors in the west are...
Okay, blue equals true.
Red equals lie.
Unless handwritten.
This one was blue, no?
This one is red!
Uh oh, so it's not unlocked.
But it looks unlocked in the video.
I mean it's wide open.
Oh wait, we don't know if that's the antechamber or not.
What else we got in here?
Hallways and storages and...
I'm scared, what if there is a baby?
I have a baby?
Oh wow, what is that?
Is that a tub?
A bathtub?
I can't tell.
Which way are we going?
We are going to the right.
Nursery!
Whenever you draft a bedroom, gain 5.
I can't do it though, I don't have any more jimmies.
But a nook would also be good because we get a key.
I think maybe the nook, no?
I think the nook would be more... because then we can also start heading up.
I'm grabbing the nook.
A journey noteworthy.
As you continue on your adventure, you may want to consider getting something to scribble down your notes and observations.
A pad, scrap of paper, or perhaps most fittingly, a journal, will prove to be an invaluable tool you will not regret having beside you on your journey.
Why is beside written like that?
Oddly forgotten!
Thank you so much for the 20 gunds, thank you!
Thank you, thank you.
Also, hi, are you German?
Hello, hello.
Why is it written like that?
I'm gonna write it down, beside.
Maybe they want me to write it.
Because they've mentioned... is there anything beside me?
Not a ghost, right?
Spooky.
Thank you, key.
Please don't be locked.
Ok.
What's... what's that?
No!
Everything's a dead end!
But I want to try the puzzle.
Well now that I have a key we can go back to the drawing room.
Or the hall... no, the hallway, I don't think I tried the other side.
Get the puzzle?
Let's try the puzzle.
Hello.
The statement on the white box is true.
Can we move to an oil rig altogether?
The only tax I have to pay is to you.
I wish.
I don't want to think about taxes, please.
I don't want to think about it.
There is a second wind-up key in this room.
Ok.
What's the first wind-up key?
The box... this box and the white box are both empty.
Wind-up key.
You found a rather curious wind-up key, a component of the parlor game.
And what does it say?
Dear Herbert, May the 2nd.
Too bad it's not May the 4th.
You need your writings beside you and not on top of your head?
Maybe.
Good playlist!
Thank you so much for the gifted, thank you!
A ViviCore, thank you for the gifted thing.
Your profile picture is scary, why do you keep changing it?
I don't like this one.
Change it!
Change it again!
May the 4th be with you.
It was a great honor receiving the invitation to dine at your estate with the old hams this past Thursday.
If I'm being frank, it had been quite a while since we had been seen in decent society, and we were beginning to worry that my wife's wit had lost its charm.
I have no delusions that my company is rival to hers.
A
ViviCore, thank you!
A Ducky, thank you for the gifted, thank you!
If I can refresh your memory, we both spent much of that evening discussing our mutual love of games and puzzles, and I had mentioned to you a rather singular parlor game I had played some years back involving three boxes of different colors.
You had pressed me to write with the particulars of this game when I found the time.
That I have included with this letter all the details you will need to share with guests should you be inclined to play this confounding game.
Always your friend, M.
Lowry.
There will always be at least one box which displays only true statements.
There will always be at least one box which displays only false statements.
Only one box has a prize within.
The other two are always empty.
Okay...
Well, what if this one's fake?
Wait, if this one's not... if this one's false...
Then... wait...
Check the sofa for money?
Move the pillows around.
Get your little fingers in there.
Wait...
There will always be at least one box which...
So, it could be two boxes that are false statements.
And that only one box has a prize within.
The other two are always empty.
And then, what did this one say?
This box and the white box are both empty.
But if...
If this one can't be false, I feel...
Because...
That would mean then there's two prizes.
But there's only one prize.
And then...
If this one's false, then there's not a second wind-up key.
Wait...
This one would be the one with the prize?
Not really, it just means both are empty.
One could have something and not the other.
Oh, I guess that's...
I guess that's fair.
It doesn't have to be...
A total annihilation.
I should've put on my glasses for this.
I don't think there's a second...
I like...
Would the wind-up key be in the box?
Wait a second, there's like little...
Little areas.
Explore.
Shando, welcome to membership.
Thank you.
It kinda doesn't help that I don't know what could possibly be in the boxes.
Like if it's only items to help you or if it also could be a wind-up key.
You know what I mean?
The second wind-up key in the box would be cheap.
That's how I feel, right?
So I feel like the white one would be false.
And then...
So that means the blue one is false as well.
It says in room, not in box.
True!
True, true, true.
Am I just like not...
There doesn't seem to be like anything I can move around or sift through.
And I can't crouch.
Gamers don't look up.
Nothing taped to the ceiling.
So black would be true.
But if they're all false...
Yes!
Adore!
Thank you so much for the 10 gift.
Thank you.
There's only one key.
So you're wrong.
There's a second wind-up key in this room.
There is not.
So you're also wrong.
And so you're right.
This box and the white box are both empty.
So then what if we try it on the blue box?
Number one is always true, yeah.
Let's try it!
Nice!
Alright, let's go back to the drawing room.
Back to the drawing table.
I gotta watch my...
My steps though.
Isn't it usually a good thing if you're getting your steps in?
I wish I could see what that note was.
The note right here.
If it was handwritten or not.
Because if it's wrong and it...
Because it said that the west...
Estates...
The west estate is usually all locked.
But if it was lying to me...
Then...
It would be where we are at now.
Don't you have to go back to the hallway anyways?
Not necessarily because this door right here in front of us was locked.
And I just got a key.
So I could technically go forward.
Here.
Or we could try going over here.
We have two directions.
Wow, I kinda like just locked myself out of this corner.
But that's okay.
It was read and typed.
It was!
Let's go try it.
It's a lie!
It's a lie, it's a lie, it's a lie.
Let's go this way.
We could gain ten steps back.
I hate this.
Why does everything just go this way?
I'm not good at building my house apparently.
We could do the spare room, true.
You know what?
We need a door that goes like this.
Yeah, let's do the spare room.
Ten steps is always nice, true.
But I'm also... I don't know.
Like so!
Oh my gosh, it's being so nice.
Food first.
Why do we need food?
What do we need food for?
Do we get more energy from that?
Let's try it.
Let's see what it means.
Hello, anybody here?
I'm curious about your wares.
The crow is true, but the boat is a lie.
Oh, today's menu.
The main... wait.
What did it say?
The main course is...
Oh yeah, banana!
Oh, I can't afford the club sandwich or the bacon and eggs.
Add morning room to today's draft pool.
Today's main course, lemon glazed salmon.
That sounds so good.
Thank you, Sammy!
Char broiled Cajun spiced salmon, lemon butter sauce served over spinach leaf.
That's exactly... oh my gosh.
If you just added rice, that's exactly...
Well, maybe not the Cajun spice, but...
Lemon.
Actually, my mom has like a great recipe for salmon.
She puts like a type of...
She like makes like a mayonnaise, something or other.
And she puts that with some capers.
I don't like the capers though.
And she puts that on the salmon and then over rice with spinach and it's so good.
Yummy, yummy, yummy, yummy.
Yummy, yummy, yummy.
Like a tartar sauce.
I don't know.
I'll have to ask her.
I'll give you guys the recipe too.
And you can have my childhood meal.
Plus 20 feet, plus an additional 10 feet if you have an aquarium in your house.
Wow.
I don't have that.
How do I get the main course?
Oh, the main course is served only in the dining room.
Let's get some banana.
Plus three steps.
Cool.
Thanks.
Now I'm hungry.
A little bit.
I don't know if I should have saved my coins, but whatever.
Where are we going?
Lava to...
What's the...
There's like nothing...
I guess west...
Oh wait, we can do the observatory.
Ah...
We need openings.
Oh wait, west wing hall gives more.
Sorry, I just noticed.
Yeah, let's do that instead.
Staff notice.
June 15th, 1983.
Out of respect for the late Lady Clara S.
Epson, the west wing will be closed until further notice.
While the floor plans associated with this wing have not been removed from the pool, we ask that staff members refrain from drafting them during this period of mourning.
Likewise, any staff may draft...
I'm in the west wing.
Are we gonna get attacked?
Look, even it's all boarded up.
Nobody's been here.
Nobody's been here for such a long time.
Oh my gosh, what if the beast is here?
Beauty and the Beast!
Let's try going up first.
Pantry.
We can get four items.
I still have a dice, I still have a key, I still have a gem.
I would have to use my gem to get the items.
It would be a dead end though, unfortunately.
It would be a dead end.
And I would like to...
Go kind of like...
But four items.
You've got two routes.
I guess it's true, we do have this one going up.
You know what, so true, let's get the four items.
I'm greedy!
Smells like old lady in here.
Another key!
Is that a security card?
Oh, an electronic keycard opens electronically powered security doors.
Which...
57188...
Which I turned all those off.
We got a diamond.
We have a purse.
Coin purse.
Each time you collect three, earn an additional one coin.
Pretty lady.
Look at that mold.
Money baby, money baby.
Anything else in here?
This guy really likes drawing.
Drawing.
Alright, let's go.
That might have been lady Clara, yeah.
Now that we have two keys.
Courtyard.
Oh my gosh, the dining room!
Wait, what?
Oh, I'm only rank...
Wait, each day a meal is served in the dining room after rank 8 has been reached.
I'm rank 4 currently.
I think that would be good because you get so...
Wait, it was like you get an additional 10 if you have the aquarium, I believe it was.
Dining room.
I'm rank 5 now!
Okay, we're just a few away.
We could have mega...
Oh, and I got an extra!
Fancy!
Oh my gosh, I'm hungry now.
Anybody having salmon tonight that I could possess?
Don't you want Mito in your body?
Controlling your every movement?
And eating your food?
I wish.
Me too.
Not salmon, but pork.
I don't know.
I've only had pho once and I didn't really like it.
Let's try going this way.
Why do I lose money going into the chapel?
Oh, all of these are kind of bad.
Oh, church donation.
How do you say that?
Titty.
You are forgiven.
Redraw, maybe.
I only have one pair of dice.
I mean, not pair.
One die.
Singular die left.
I don't know what you do to get more rank.
I guess that...Oh wait.
So it would be 1, 2, 3, 4, 5.
So this is what?
6, 7, 8.
Wait, I should have gone up instead.
I'm an idiot.
No!
You can do the chapel and not go in.
You're so right.
Then we at least have this option here, no?
Going to church to pay the big old...
Tie.
Yeah, the chapel does go north and it also...Wait, no.
I looked wrong.
For some reason I thought it went to the right as well.
I think that would be...Or I could just re-roll.
I'm gonna re-roll.
I feel like we can get some better options in this.
Oh, see?
Like the cool...
Locksmith?
Keys for sale?
What a fun shaped room.
I know, right?
It looks so fascinating.
Why is this...I don't know why this is also giving me...
Oh my gosh, do you guys remember that book series, A Series of Unfortunate Events?
It's not really at all like that, but it's kind of giving me the vibe...
of it.
Just like because it's a little gothic, you know?
And you're just in the...I don't know.
There's just something about it.
All the different types of areas you can go into.
Oh, the aesthetic.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Like the reptile house.
Yeah, exactly!
When I look at the courtyard, I think of that.
I think I'm gonna go with the courtyard because it's kind of our best option out of the...
out of the three.
But, we will go north.
And we can pantry.
I can't get the observatory.
We shall pantry.
Okay.
Is that a banana?
Just here?
Oh my god!
Lucky, lucky!
Wow!
Nice.
T-t-t-t-t-the Tithi in the Roaming Chapel.
So if I go to other pantries, I can get more food?
If I unlock more pantries?
That was our first!
And we got plus three.
Nooooo!
Wait a second.
Oh, after rank 8 has been reached.
Okay, I was about to say, because we went down to rank 5...
And I was like, should I have made the dining room up here?
But no, it says only after it's been reached, so we're okay.
We are A-okay!
What is this?
I got a shovel.
Looks like it could be useful for digging.
Okay!
What do we...
Like this?
A turnip!
Plus six.
Oh my gosh, let's go!
Woah.
Oh my gosh, I was about to be like...
If it's locked, we're so screwed.
Conference room.
Whenever items would be spread throughout the house, they are placed in this room instead.
Combine inventory to create new items?
Wait, but conference room seems OP, no?
Wait, you can dig more?
Oh, whoops.
I think
you want conference room before workshop.
Okay.
Yeah, I think so too.
Getting more stuff.
Where do you see another place to dig?
Ah, I missed it!
Thank you guys.
Coins!
We're so stinking rich, baby.
This is false.
So I'm not even gonna write it down.
Reminder, after meeting adjourns, take all conference notes and place them in the office safe.
Okay.
Wait, what?
Huh?
There's no items in here.
Wait, some special rooms allow you to spread items throughout your house.
When items are spread, they are immediately placed in several of the rooms currently on your estate.
However, if you have a conference room, spread items are gathered in that room instead.
I guess I should have spread my items.
Ah, I see.
I think.
I see.
No!
Guys, we are almost at an impasse.
If I can get back to the entrance hall, I can go this way.
But...
This one is locked.
This one is locked and this one is locked.
Uh-oh.
We gotta go back all the way.
Back.
Locksmith, please.
We gotta go all the way back.
Yeah.
This kinda sucks.
Okay.
Getting those steps in.
Opportunity to URD and spread.
Combine inventory and create new items.
I might do the workshop just so we can then get another room.
URD and spread.
Yes.
Yeah, I don't have any gems.
So what can I combine, baby?
Is there anything else?
Maybe a key is in here.
I've got a lock.
A lockpick kit!
What?
I'm gonna combine my this.
Combine my this.
Combine this.
I don't think any of this makes much sense.
And a wheel.
What is this?
The true box does not always contain the prize.
Good to know.
Well, we learned that from the last time we got a puzzle.
Okay.
I think we have to risk it with the closet.
There was a note next to the lockpick.
Oh, was there?
There's a note on the table.
Okay, I'll go check.
I think the closet is better than the guest bedroom.
Stones cut blank by hand, and letters rot blank.
Do spell blank our secrets carved from thought.
A message is often lost among the bold blank words spoken soft.
The note is read, the letter is not blank.
Well, those aren't blanks.
Oh, they are blanks?
I meant that sheet music.
Yeah?
I've never seen it elongated like that before though.
They're like sustains.
Oh.
Got it.
I can't sight read anymore.
So I'm not even going to attempt.
Stones cut by hand and letters rot.
Do spell our secrets carved from thought.
A message read is often lost among the bold words spoken soft.
The note is read, the letter is not.
Okay.
This one's number eight.
How do you screenshot on Steam again?
Again?
How do you... how do you... how do you screen... F12?
Thank you.
Alright.
E.
Wait, so that was... it said eight?
Hold on.
Sheet... I don't know if sheet music eight...
means anything.
But message was bolded.
My pen is running out.
And then E...
in stone.
Okay.
Alright, let's go in here and hope and pray and wish.
What is... oh it's a lucky... lucky tail!
Foot!
Greater chance of finding items.
Thank you so much for the superchat.
Well, I wish I had that...
I wish I had that before!
Okey-dokey.
Let's try the drawing room.
Maybe.
No... wait, hold on.
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7.
1, 2, 3, 4... you know what, it's just whatever.
To the pantry.
Wait a second.
I have a lot of money!
Yeah!
I have money!
I can buy... I can buy...
And morning room.
Let's try that.
Wait, I should have done the plus 15.
Oh well.
It's fine.
I want to know what the morning room is.
If we even end up getting it.
If we can get the glazed salmon...
Lockpick.
No!
Wait!
Reroll!
I have no... I have no jammies!
I don't want the lavatory!
Reroll!
They are fancy.
Their family crest is also fancy.
Anything else in here?
What's good?
What good is this rabbit's foot?
There is nothing in here.
It smells like Batara.
Dirt?
Oh my gosh.
You guys are so... Thank you.
Turnip!
Thank you guys.
Thank you, thank you.
Okay.
Let's try and use our lockpick on this.
My room!
Oh, but it... You know what?
That's fine.
The drawing room can... It's fine.
This room counts as two bedrooms.
Interesting.
Less likely to find items lying around in your house.
Wait, that's not good.
We don't want... Wait.
Oh no!
Yeah, that's bad.
What is the only choice we've got?
You know what?
This run is over anyway.
What do you mean it's not over?
I still have... I still have... I'm still here!
I'm still here, no?
Woah, my family.
This guy looks spooky.
Eight people.
Any staff who have an interest in attending services may contact Mrs. Babbage for details.
In following the instructions left by the Baron himself, effective immediately, all work at Mount Holly is suspended.
All live-in staff will have one month paid leave and must vacate the premises by Friday, November 6th.
Mrs. Babbage.
Okay, that's why nobody's here.
This game is so eerie.
This game is so creepy.
This is the ugliest maid uniform.
What actually is going on here?
This is the worst maid uniform I've ever seen in my entire afterlife.
What is happening?
What did Picasso make this?
Terrible.
Repulsive.
The worst I've ever seen.
Damn the person who said this run was dead.
Damn you!
The run is over.
You know what?
I never got to have my salmon.
I never got to have it.
It smells so good.
I'm not gonna...
I'm just gonna run out of...
That scared me.
I thought it was a mannequin.
Wait, we have a pet?
Is there a cat here?
Looking for dirt?
You know what?
That's a good idea too.
Let's search for dirt.
It could be dirt that we completely... Wait, let's go outside.
There
might be dirt out here.
Wait, can I just leave?
Wait...
Wow!
Who is...
The campsite.
Due to the rules set forth in your great uncle's will, you are not allowed to stay in the estate overnight.
Luckily, however, your scouting skills have been put to good use to fabricate a very respectable off-site sleeping quarters.
Interesting.
What is he making there?
Cider?
I'm gonna do it.
Sorry, Gramps.
What else we got?
There was something over here too.
What the?
Um...
Okay.
Gramps was ready for doomsday.
Understandable.
Don't do it.
I'm gonna do it.
What if we just found a key out here?
Wouldn't that be just... so... special?
Wait, is there a front door mat?
Grandpa...
What's down there?
Wait a second.
There's so much around here.
I'm gonna lose my jammies.
Am I?
I wonder.
Make a wish?
Wait.
Oh, it's a bird.
I can make a wish.
I wish for a key.
Grandpa...
If you can hear me...
I wish for a key.
I'm not asking for much.
All I need is one.
Is this also locked or...
Just jump, buddy.
Just jump.
It doesn't seem as locked for some reason though.
I won't budge.
Like it's not saying that I need a key for it.
Ah...
Oh wait, there's down here too.
Woah!
Oh my gosh, remember I said, Grandpa, what mind do you have?
What is up with that mountain?
It's kinda freaky.
What?
Hole?
Wait.
We have an underground society?
I think this game is a little more complex than I first imagined it to be.
Wait, what if we find a key in here?
Wait.
Oh, this is really scary.
And I don't have a lighter.
This is kinda freaky.
Let's get out of here.
Can I go in there?
No.
Okay.
I'm just gonna run out of steps.
A haunted mansion episode of Over the Garden Wall?
Yes!
Yeah, it reminds me of that too.
Where they just kept building and building.
It's so much like that.
Oh, well good.
We at least got to explore some.
Grandpa liked birds.
We at least got to explore a little bit.
That's always nice.
That's always good to do.
Oh shoot, I just gained more.
Wait, I just noticed these.
What are those?
Wait.
Are these the little sparkles you get from the observatory?
Perhaps.
Twinkle dogs.
Maybe?
Oh man, I should have been...
Every time that I got an observatory though, it wasn't the right time.
Ah, I see, I see, I see.
Hot queen of diamonds.
I'll see you again soon.
Maybe.
Let's see if there's any more dirt to...
Oh, this too!
Well, I wouldn't waste my key on it.
But...
Any dirt in the security room?
What does that say?
Oh, B cam, A cam.
We got six rooms left, guys.
What was it?
Five.
Four.
Three.
Two.
One.
Zero.
Wow.
Do I get to keep my gemmies?
Because I earned those, I feel.
Mount Holly.
Mid-sized villa.
Total rooms 24, rank reach 6, steps taken 86, items found 7.
I feel like we were so close.
Save and continue, of course.
Yeah, mid-sized says who?
Says who?
Yeah, we did learn a lot.
This game is so cool.
Good morning, Minto!
Alrighty!
She's here!
Wait, are the flowers different?
Or were they these flowers before?
Four.
Let's go forward!
Wait, this bedroom actually has a...
Good start.
I can't tell if you're being sarcastic or not.
Straight into the lavatory.
I haven't unlocked a lavatory before.
Let's do the bedroom.
Just like before.
Wow, wait, it's the same exact bedroom.
Oh, this is so trippy.
This is so trippy.
Oh, but...
Oh my gosh.
The storeroom might be nice.
Oh wait, the nook would be good too.
Let's do that.
Oh my gosh, I feel like I'm going to get lost.
Because I'm not going to remember.
Oh, this one too!
This too has four stars.
Interesting, okay.
So if I get four observatories, maybe we try coming back here.
Lost in the sauce.
I know.
No, wait, can I go into debt in this game?
Let's try it.
Can I go into debt?
I can't!
Oh, yippee!
One.
There's no two.
Oh, there it is.
The pantry.
The chef is two.
Three is the farmer.
Four is the chimney sweep.
Five is the maid.
Six is...
What is that?
Like a horse?
I'm not quite sure.
What are they?
A jockey?
Chicken jockey!
Partner's birthday was yesterday and you're his Kamiyoshi.
Can I get a happy birthday for NEP?
Of course!
NEP, happy birthday!
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday dear NEP.
Happy birthday!
Seven.
Wait a second.
Are these
things that unlock when you get to that rank?
Because I feel like we unlocked the... I feel like it was about rank five, no?
That we unlocked the maid quarters.
And...
Two.
Makes sense, yeah?
You can read room descriptions by clicking on them.
Oh, neat.
Oh!
Bedrooms, hallways, green rooms, shops, red rooms.
So red rooms are not good to have because they...
Red rooms are bad.
We want to get less of those.
Let's try going this way.
Yeah.
Ow.
I guess the den would be our best bet here.
Red room, red room.
Spare bedroom.
Drawing room.
Why is nothing going up?
Sucks.
Let's go spare.
I suppose.
Oh wait!
I just realized I got the gem.
I'm such an idiot.
No!
I forgot.
Let's try this one.
Oh, the security room.
Already.
And west...
View inventory... Oh wait.
And of all items... Oh, I didn't realize.
Okay, hold on.
Hold on.
View the items.
How do I see that?
Oh wait, this...
What's that?
How do you see the items?
Am I stupid?
Enter.
I didn't notice this was a thing.
The following is a detailed list of items currently in the house that have yet to be collected.
This list will be updated as new rooms are added.
Okay.
Main menu.
Keycard system.
Security doors are open within...
The estate...
Wait.
You got any games on this thing?
We got Snake on here.
The keycard system is currently operational.
Keycard system settings.
Set security level...
To...
Low.
Wait.
Security level determines the amount of keycard security doors that will be deployed in your estate.
Example, you should expect to see one or two security doors with a low setting.
Five to six with a high setting.
I imagine though that...
Let's just keep it as is.
Because if we can get another security... We had the keycard before.
If we can get another one, we'll be Gucci.
But...
I imagine better things are behind...
The security doors.
No?
So...
Change offline mode.
As a general rule of safety, offline should be set to unlocked if any staff are working on the estate.
This mode determines the default setting to security doors will be set to if power is lost.
During a blackout, for example.
Unlocked.
I think there's no harm in doing that.
Yeah, you can raise it back once you get the keycard.
You know what?
That's true.
I mean, we'd have to come all the way back here, but...
Wow.
Thank you.
I did not notice.
The security door is locked by an electronic keycard.
Oh.
Already?
Oh!
Oh, there was a raid!
Hello!
Thank you!
Sorry, I didn't see who raided me, but thank you!
Hello, hello!
Thank you so much for the raid!
This game is a roguelike puzzle game.
Where you explore a house.
I'm selling it, probably.
Wait a second.
Okay, the spare room might be our only hope.
You're our only hope.
Corridor.
So pretty.
I do also want to unlock more different types of rooms, so I'm fine with trying some other things out, you know?
Oh, we can do the... Oh!
The parlor!
Okay!
Okay, one box will only display true.
At least one will be true.
At least one will be false.
And there will be one prize, okay?
Same as before.
Let's go, baby!
What do we got?
This box is the white box.
I don't think that's right.
Dwarko, thank you so much for the 10 gilded.
This box is the black box.
This, the blue box, contains the gems.
Today is my brother, Mediocre Monk's birthday.
Could you sing happy birthday?
Thank you, Fiddy!
Thank you!
Thank you for the super chat!
Of course I can sing.
Dear brother, happy birthday!
This is the orange box.
Happy birthday to you!
Happy birthday, Mediocre Monk!
You're not so mediocre!
Happy birthday to you!
Happy birthday!
Let's make our little...
Oh wait.
Oh no.
Oh, well, we can do the breaker then.
I think that would be good to have that available.
Keycard off.
Dark room.
And we still didn't learn what this is before either.
So far we haven't gone super far, but...
Wait, why is it so dark?
Where are we at?
A closet?
West wing hall I think would be best.
Trying to go up is...
Now set security doors to high.
Neat.
Okay, so that worked perfectly.
Keycard system.
System settings.
Set security level to high.
Confirm.
Thanks for reminding me guys.
Perfect, perfect.
All according to Minky.
My queen!
Hmm...
I'm just going to keep trying to go north.
Oh, well...
Hold on.
Is this one locked?
Mug!
Welcome to Batboy's ship.
Wow, this one is kind of fancy.
Wait, but the pantry...
Pantry goes up.
Marvelous monk.
What would you guys say?
The passageway requires...
You know what pantries give you.
True.
Save your gems?
Okay.
I feel like using the passageway there is kind of a waste anyway, no?
Okay, we got one apple.
And more money.
Unfortunately, if I want to go back to the spare room though, I have to give up some money for the chapel.
But, so far we are doing alright.
So far.
The courtyard is pretty good.
Oh, that might actually...
Yes.
And that will put us at...
I've read the note.
I'm pretty sure it's the same as before.
Saying that there's like...
Yeah, five apples, five bananas, five oranges.
So if we get more pantries unlocked, then we will...
Oh, we don't get a shovel this time.
We get a sledgehammer.
Can shatter padlocks on locked trunks.
Okay.
I don't think we've seen a locked trunk though.
I kind of wanted the shovel.
Oh, sorry.
No, no, no.
We're all good.
We might have not been here.
It's all good.
I guess that's kind of the interesting thing about this roguelike is some of the notes...
I guess the further we get beyond, we will get more new stuff.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I wish it would work.
I was thinking the sledgehammer maybe would work on locked doors.
Sadly, no.
Hmm.
Patio.
Spread gems in each green room.
Which I only have one.
A garage.
Or we can do a guest bedroom and get ten more stuppies.
You need an axe like the Shining.
Here's Mickey.
Oh, the garage gives you more keys.
Oh my gosh.
Garage is in the breaker room.
Yes.
Did I turn it on?
Three keys is huge.
I'm not going to lie.
I did turn it on.
Yay.
I'm so smart.
What is this?
Oh.
Wait.
Christoph, this is the third time this month you and the car have been gone when your services were required.
I don't care how long you have been driving for his lordship.
His lordship.
Your absences must be accounted for.
Mrs. Babbage.
The music in this game is so nice.
Oh my gosh.
Dobby is a free elf.
And look.
We made it past.
This is the run everybody.
Oh.
Shelter protects you from the negative effects of the next three red rooms drafted.
Rooms in your house will be more likely to contain dig spots today.
Or tool shed.
I don't feel like... I mean, I don't have a shovel so...
This is freaking me out.
Yeah, the radiation.
The shed.
I'm curious what red...
So the bathroom is... I'm sorry, the lavatory is a red room but like...
What's bad about it?
I guess it doesn't give you any...
Any... anything?
Chapel is red too.
Yeah.
The chapel, you lose one coin.
Let's go tool shed.
I'm thinking the same thing.
Because it wouldn't affect the... It says the next three drafted.
And so, it would not apply, unfortunately.
So let's do... I'm so curious.
Look at the stairs and it goes down.
Let's do the tool shed for practicality, I believe.
Oh yeah, the maid room too.
We got ourselves a shovel!
Let's see.
I figured that would happen.
And a metal detector.
Greater chance of finding keys and money!
Nice, and what's our third thing?
What's our third thing?
It said three items, no?
Wait, what's our... What's the third?
Hello?
Wait.
Did it say three special items?
Oh, just two.
OK, I can't read.
Good find though, I'd say.
I love this music.
I wonder if the OST is on Steam.
Oh, the gate.
Thank you.
The west gate has been permanently unlocked!
That's huge!
Oh my gosh, that's huge!
Nice.
So it kind of pays.
I guess because we were on the west wing wall, we were able to unlock the garage.
And it kind of led us out into this area.
So, so cool.
And then what's over here?
So I wonder if we can unlock stuff on the east wing then.
Very cool.
And we can dig here.
Dig, dig, dig.
Turn up!
Yummy, yummy, yummy.
Hammer the trunk?
Wait, did I miss a trunk?
Wait.
I don't think...
It wouldn't let me... Oh wait!
No, I... Wait, I think I just messed up.
Because this one, it didn't give me an option to.
Sorry, I already had the hammer at that point.
Sorry, I messed up.
I shouldn't have...
Ah!
It's fine.
I'm gonna play this game more now.
Have fun!
Okay, anyway.
It's fine.
I just lost a couple steps, but it's fine.
Yeah, see?
The lavatory doesn't... Maybe because it doesn't give you anything.
But also this hallway!
I do not have any gems, so I can't unlock the kitchen anyway, but this hallway is a pretty good...
...other dig spot.
Thank you, gaze.
Thank you.
More cards!
Minto, while writing finals papers.
Three pages left.
Oh, Envero, you got this!
You've got this, you've got this.
Oh, my metal detector.
Doors in the west... Okay, that's false.
Most likely.
Oh, my god!
It worked!
Hey, I always forget that spot.
My bad.
Okay, drawing room.
I don't... I can't... I can't... I can't afford it.
No!
And once you have drawn floor plans, you must select one.
Maybe I should have gone to the right.
I'm gonna do the guest bedroom.
So that we can get ten more steps.
I think so.
I think right now...
Also, I haven't crafted this room before, so...
I cheated you!
So we can get new notes and stuff too.
Sinclair, just wanted to write you a quick note thanking you for the weekend.
I had a thrilling time on the hunt with Lord Evanson, whose peculiar personality somewhat made up for your own absence.
I also got to appreciate your new game in the billiard room.
It's been ages since I've seen the billiard room in the house.
I was beginning to suspect you retired the floor plan.
Is everyone just okay with the house being like this?
Is this just like a...
Is this just how everyone's like, yep, this is just the house.
It was well worth the wait though, as I always enjoyed your mathematical puzzles and appreciated that I didn't need to know the rules of darts to play your variation.
Okay, interesting.
So we have a dart puzzle perhaps, maybe.
Hoping your health improves shortly.
KL?
Is that what that says?
Everyone's just fine with all of this happening.
Aww, little pup.
Okay, well that was kind of stinky, but...
We can maybe save this.
I
think I'm gonna go for the kitchen.
We still have one more.
We still have this too.
And the spare room.
And the entrance hall, I don't know.
Do we have a couple?
The food!
Wait, the food here has not been eaten yet!
And the water!
It was eaten in the last one.
We have... we have a mice problem.
Maybe.
What's today?
Porter House Steak!
A delightfully expensive steak cut.
Bone-in and extra marbled for maximum tenderness.
A perfect dish for those who love extravagance.
You know what I had today?
Popcorn chicken.
Yeah, chef salad for every green room.
I think I only have one, no?
Just one.
Club sandwich, plus 15.
Banana!
I don't think I need it right now though.
Ah!
I kind of want to finish my... I didn't finish my popcorn chicken.
What should we do?
I do still have three keys left.
Use it?
Yeah.
Use.
I was wondering if I should go all the way to the other place, but...
Ah, commissary.
No!
I don't have a gem anymore.
Okay, let's just hope for some good items.
I haven't unlocked the bunk bedroom either before, so...
We're unlocking new stuff at least.
Oh my god!
A gerbil!
Oh, he's so cute!
Oh my god, he's so cute!
Wait, who's feeding you?
I'm scared.
Is there more?
More money.
Okay, that's everything.
No keys in this room?
The turtles of Vera.
Who is feeding you?
Oh my gosh, what if you have to feed your gerbil and you can't find your room?
No key, no key.
Today is a good day because Simon is at camp and he is not as much fun as my friends.
I will not have to share my toys and will not have to share my room and I will not have to share my snacks.
Having a younger brother is not as much fun as they told me it would be.
But today will be a good day because he is at camp.
Gerbil!
Oh sorry, not gerbil.
Herbie is mean and really stupid and today is a good day because I threw away his airplane.
P.S.
I wrote this in Herbie's blood, right?
I also had more fun at camp than he has had in his entire life.
Today is a good day because I got my brother in trouble for reading my private journal without my permission and writing mean things in it too.
Also he threw my model airplane in the bushes outside but I got it back and if he does it again he will not get to go to the park on Friday and I...
Oh wait, and yeah, I will make sure he gets no presents for his birthday.
They told him he wanted a brother.
They lied.
I don't need any presents because I have my brother's book because he won't stop writing about me.
And today is a good day because I know he cries when he can't find his book even though he is older.
He is a crybaby.
Oh.
Today is a good day because today my brother returns from college and I get to finally return to him the book I took from him a long, long time ago.
Hopefully you will find it as hilarious as I do.
I honestly have no idea how we survived sharing a room.
All things being said, I still would rather have had a sister.
Congrats on the diploma and welcome home, Simon.
That's so sweet.
So cute.
Oh my god, please run.
Yeah, look at him.
Wow, he is going really fast.
Oh my god.
Herbal.
My brother is calling me Herbie.
Wait, what?
And says all of this is really relatable.
Should I be afraid?
And why can't I find my paper airplane?
Camp Colonel.
The Trinsdale Mystery.
They got games in their room.
All we got was money though.
I guess we can buy some stuff.
Like we can buy some food.
I could get the club sandwich.
For some more steps.
I guess it's worth it for now.
Especially because this run is looking a little tough.
I have to go back through the chapel.
Wait, if I go into this, do I get plus ten every time?
Or is it just the first time I go in?
Oh, I can go outside.
You're right.
Take the garage.
You're right, you're right.
Just the first time.
Wouldn't it be cool?
I thought that maybe because he talked about...
The plane being in the bushes.
If maybe when we went out here we could find it.
I thought I saw a coin.
Nice.
Okay.
To the spare room.
Wait, how do we... Oh, I do have to still go...
What?
No.
I'm going to go to the right of the entrance hall instead.
Make a wish.
I wish that we can go around.
We have to get insane luck here.
Okay, drawing.
Don't have any gems.
Old Clannad art toggle win.
It's not even Clannad!
This is not even Clannad!
Okay, to the spare room.
Our only hope.
You're our only hope, spare room Kenobi.
The runner is dead.
The runner is dead!
We can craft some new rooms that we have not done before.
I guess the boudoir sounds kind of fancy.
We can at least go to other places.
I have no idea what's going on, but Minkikyu...
Basically...
Trying to go up here, but we're in a roguelike.
She took off her shoes.
Is there really nothing in here?
Wait, what's this?
Christmas!
Interesting.
Okay, someone got a safe for Christmas.
Interesting, interesting.
Why are there so many ladies shoes around here?
Let's see, what do we want to get?
This is just mocking me now.
I want to try the lavatory since I've never gotten it, but...
What are you picking up?
Oh, some coins.
Passageway?
Conference room?
Dining room.
Oh, these are lame.
Minky is cute, pass it on.
No!
Let's just...
I've unlocked both before, so...
This one?
Billiard room!
Mail room.
A package will be delivered here on the day after drafting this room.
Wait, so...
If I...
Well, probably this would be better than the billiard then.
Yeah, mail room for the next run.
Order placed!
That's so exciting.
Simon P. Jones.
Dad.
Mount Holly Estate.
Hey buddy, how's it going up there in that big house?
I think most people would be pretty scared being alone for this length of time, but I have a feeling you're doing just fine.
I imagine you're happy as a clam, perfectly content on the estate, with the exploration and opportunities for adventure that present themselves each day.
As I'm writing this, you're currently in the garage packing...
Oh, in the garage packing the tent!
I wanted to try to post this letter before we depart tomorrow so that it has a chance to arrive during your first few days on the estate.
But with all the preparations, I'm not sure that I'm going to find the time.
There's so much I want to say, and I'm sure I'll forget to tell you Friday night.
Sometimes it's easier for me to just jot this stuff down.
You're yelling at me right now to come bring you a pillowcase.
Hold on a second, I'll be right back.
I can tell you're really excited, but I think you might feel a little guilty about being so happy the day after the funeral.
Believe me, I know how long Uncle Herbert...
Oh, Herbie!
...worked on setting this up for you.
And I know from our conversations just how much happiness this final project brought him.
So do both of us a favor, be excited.
This house really is amazing.
I know it's been almost seven years since we were last up there, and I'm really curious to hear just how much you remember from those summer trips.
You've always been smarter than me at this kind of thing, so I'm not sure how much guidance or inspiration I can offer before your trip...
...that will actually be useful to you.
Despite my best intentions, I'm sure that on Friday, I'll end up leaving you with a few of my overused clich expressions when we say farewell.
Later, alligator!
Dad.
P.S.
Get some sleep each night and don't spend all your time each day planning...
D-D-Dirigiblox?
The hell is that?
Is that supposed to be Minecraft?
Minecraft?
I wanna play...
Dirigiblox.
This room is so quiet.
Royal mail?
Wait, what's this?
Utility room feels like more detailed instructions will be sent by electronic mail to the address the client has provided.
Press any button to activate blue.
Press the blue indicator next to red to activate purple.
Five purple indicators are needed to activate the sixth.
Aha!
Nice.
Please return all correspondence and packages addressed to Denny Ravain to sender...
...as he is no longer...
As he is no longer...
Wait.
As he no longer is employed with our staff.
I wonder if he watched the Dirigiblox movie.
Wait.
Oh god.
Can you read that?
What?
What does that say?
You need an item.
Something about stealing the baron's mail.
Beatrice's symbol from Umineko.
Closer to the screen.
I'm reading it.
Did...
Ever prove...
He was the one that stole...
The baron's mail.
Did they ever prove?
Did they ever prove that he was the one to steal the baron's mail?
So, Denny is a menace.
Hold on.
I'm gonna write that down.
Denny sucks and steals mail.
Denny...
Ravaine...
Just in case there is more than one.
Sucks...
And steals...
Mail...
Fired.
I don't need an item.
I just need my eyes.
My eyes are the prize.
My eyes are items.
Cool.
I think we could just...
Go to sleep then.
Since this is a dead run, officially.
So sad.
I can't make it past...
I can't make it past here.
Past six.
Call it a day.
The fuse box?
I don't think that would...
Wait, try the breaker box.
Wait, what do you mean, Maya?
What do you mean the breaker box?
Check the boudoir?
Why?
What did I miss in here?
This...
Lighting?
Oh, I have the code!
Oh, you're right, you're right, you're right, you're right, you're right.
I think the safe is in here.
I didn't see it though.
Well, let's just go back.
I don't wanna waste another step.
All my money!
Security...
Behind the screen.
Oh, maybe I missed it then.
Okay, I'll trust you guys.
I'll trust you guys.
Okay, so for this...
Wait.
Oh, wait, okay.
Wait, what do I have to click?
I had it before.
Ah!
Do I click this?
You screenshotted it, right?
How do I access Steam screenshots?
Yes.
Tab.
My screenshots!
Thank you!
Thank you, Rob.
Okay,
press the blue...
to make it purple.
Uh-oh.
There we go, okay.
Why did it turn that one?
Okay.
I did it.
That's what it looks like in the screenshot.
One more click of the red one.
Oh!
Uh...
Okay.
Maybe we'll go to the...
Safe?
Yeah, we need one more message for the e-mail.
Yeah, I said that we would get another...
We gotta get another e-mail message or something.
Maybe it will be sent here.
Did you play Myst?
My dad played Myst.
And I attempted Myst.
Any other game puzzles that make you simmer with rage at remembering them in any game?
Nothing I can think of.
Okay, main menu.
Oh, I don't know the password.
Let's just try going back to the boudoir.
This is a pretty dead run anyway, so...
Oh, I see it here.
Ah!
A-0-0-A-5.
Okay.
We don't have that yet.
Dang it.
It's not your safe.
I got a hint?
Wait, want the hint?
You can figure it out in this room.
Is it 12-25?
Christmas?
Or 25-12?
Where were you?
Four.
Herbert, I was distraught to learn that you have chosen to omit the details of our dear Marion's disappearance from the public record.
It is no surprise to me that the Royal Court would want this embarrassment kept as quiet as possible.
But I am shocked that you have so little regard for your niece that you would play this King's Skullion.
That was my birthday two days ago!
Janie, happy birthday!
Happy birthday to you!
Happy birthday, dear Janie!
Dobbs Marsh.
Happy birthday to you!
Happy birthday!
And stoop to kissing the foot that treads upon her memory.
She gave up her family, her fortune, and her life, and all you can do is think of your name.
Having never had a family name nor fortune of my own, I cannot personally condemn you for faltering in your commitment to make the same sacrifice as she did.
But for the love of God, do not buy that same display of weakness, clutch your petty assets so tightly that you undermine the cause that she forfeited everything to further.
Our countrymen must be made aware of the price she paid and must be made to see the color of the flag she flew as she rode into the darkness of a hundred nights.
To deny her story is to deny her life.
Oh, Daniel.
If through your silence you bless this betrayal, our son Simon, your heir will inherit a fortune of lies and will spit upon your grave when he learns of your cursed foolishness.
Needless to say, we will not be coming for Christmas this year.
Daniel.
The handwriting changed?
Oh, yeah, you're right.
It did change.
Damn, Daniel.
No, wait.
No, it didn't.
The H's are still the same.
But
it's like this has italics and this doesn't.
Because you can see the H in the and the H here are both the same.
It just has italics or not.
The boss strikes again.
The slant changed.
Yeah, yeah.
Look at the capitals.
Yeah, it's just the slant.
So this feels like I should write something down.
Like so Marion.
I don't know who that is.
Where'd my pen go?
I lost it.
Oh, just kidding.
I have it.
Marion.
Disappeared.
I feel like I need to draw like a family tree.
And then dad is Daniel.
But what?
We don't know why she disappeared.
Or if she's... I don't understand.
She got Isekai'd.
Yeah.
Our son.
Simon.
That's us.
So...
So our dad is Daniel.
Okay.
I'm not good with names.
So I'm gonna be really...
I'm gonna be really bad unless I write this down.
Okay.
So we have a sister?
Maybe?
Interesting.
Alright.
Shall we call it a day?
Thanks, guys, for the help with the...
safe.
That was very...
helpful.
That was good.
We got some...
Some...
Some information at least.
So...
Call it a day.
Not in the stream.
Just in the game.
Actually...
I might call it a day in the stream.
It's been a little shorter, but I...
I had a pretty long day, so...
Yeah, we got the permanent unlock.
That was huge!
Maybe... Okay.
Maybe I won't.
Maybe I'll do one more day.
I'll do one more day.
I really like this game, so I kind of want to keep going.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
We'll do one more day.
One more day.
Don't leave yet!
Don't leave!
And a drink because of my spicy...
I accidentally got spicy popcorn chicken.
I didn't notice it was spicy.
So give me a second.
Wait, is there music at least?
Yeah.
You can listen.
I'll be right back.
I am back.
And with my dinner lunch.
Yay!
Yay, yay, yay.
Shall we continue?
Hmm.
Hmm!
Wait, what is this red letter here now?
Dinner lunch at 10.
Well, I had it for lunch and I didn't finish it, so now it's dinner.
I didn't eat anything before this.
I had a late lunch.
Was it late?
No.
Hope you're doing well.
Thank you!
Let's not go forward first.
Let's go this way.
Hmm.
Sorry, I was so spicy.
I'm okay.
The shed.
Yes.
I'm gonna grab two items.
We might need a key for the shed, so maybe there's gonna be one in here.
Okay, dye is good.
And gemmy is good.
I like that.
Let's go back outside.
I'm okay.
Let's go check it out.
The shed.
Oh, we don't.
Hopeful?
Special floor plans now cost additional feet instead of a gem.
Wait.
Wait a second.
That was our big...
That was our big problem last time.
I couldn't progress because I didn't have gemmies.
Let's...
We'll have to be careful of our feet, but I think this will be good.
Sorry, I'm eating this, but I'm drinking a lot of milk too.
Good for the feet economy.
Notice of termination.
This is...
Denny, you suck, Denny.
Notice of termination.
Dear Mr. Ravain, Your half-hearted dedication and maintenance of the grounds have been greatly appreciated.
However, I regret to inform you that your services as the groundskeeper at Mount Holly will no longer be required.
Effective immediately.
So he was the groundskeeper.
Hold on, I'm writing that down.
Groundskeeper.
This decision has been made after careful consideration and is based upon repeated observations and documented instances of neglect in the performance of your duties.
The state of the green rooms in particular has deteriorated significantly over the last few months, which reflects poorly on the rest of the staff.
You are required to vacate the hovel by the 20th of March, ensuring all tools and equipment belonging to the estate are returned to the tool shed in good condition.
Your final wages will be settled promptly upon completion of these instructions.
We thank you for your time and service and wish you the best in your future endeavors.
Anne Babbage, House Manager Yikes.
Oh my god, that's all he has for a bed?
He was cookin'.
Where is room 46?
Wait, was he trying to get my... he's trying to steal my inheritance!
Coincidence?
7590.
Tested my full house theory.
No luck, as expected.
What do you mean two starting rooms?
Does he count the outside as a starting room?
I mean, you do lose steps when you...
When you go outside.
Interesting.
The mystery.
This sad, sad bed.
You know what, Denny, maybe you just... maybe...
Maybe it's for the best.
Oh?
Oh, that's where that is?
Did I just help you solve a puzzle?
You're welcome.
I'm a bit of a genius.
Okay.
Alright.
So that...
Was pretty good.
I'm starting to think that the end goal...
Of this game is basically Clue, the board game.
Yeah, I know, right?
Family drama edition and set up by grandpa.
Maybe, yeah.
Wait, so if I...
Don't... Oh, I can't go this way because I don't have it.
Okay.
I'm three-fourths of the fires.
Oh no!
You'll get it.
Where did that light up anyway?
Like over...
Oh, I can't make a wish yet.
Over here?
Yes.
Exciting!
Exciting, exciting, exciting.
Let's go back in.
So now anything that needs a gem is free.
That's exciting.
Or not free, but...
Let's do the pantry.
Oh!
My package has been delivered!
Wait, but this is... This will... You know what?
It's fine.
Let's get the package.
Package delivered.
This one?
Packing slip.
The Sinka Company.
K.
Thompson.
Do we know a K.
Thompson yet?
Grass compass, two gems, two keys.
Oh!
Five, two, five, four.
I'm gonna...
Just in case.
No way!
Draws floor plans leading north more frequently!
That's awesome.
Oh yeah, that's good!
Oh yeah, baby!
Okay, I don't think there's anything else in here, so...
Cooking now, for real.
So now if we try to... This is our only way.
The den.
We shall go.
It sucks though, because a lot of these rooms were getting gemmies, but I guess... I wish I could sell them.
You know?
Wait!
Do you think I should use it on this or no?
I feel like if I have an excess...
It would be good, but...
Maybe later.
Yeah, I wouldn't personally... Yeah, I think so too.
Check one item and retrieve it on another day.
Interesting, okay.
We have a hallway.
We have a corridor.
I think we'll go with the hallway.
Corridor?
Why?
Because it's always unlocked?
I don't know what that means yet though.
I haven't experienced anything being locked.
Oh, do you mean because this door is always unlocked?
For some reason I was thinking like with the security keys or... You know, stuff like that.
Or like if the power goes out, you know, the other doors lock.
I don't know what I'm thinking, okay?
I feel we are too slow for it to be...
For it to be like a security door, but let's just go with the corridor then.
Better later in the run, I see.
What do we got?
Oh, wow.
Oh my gosh, you guys were...
Everything is pointing north!
So this will require...
Okay, the gemmy thing might kick us in the ass now because I have four gemmies!
Sorry, I'm eating and thinking at the same time.
Could be pricey, it could.
But we unlocked that early game, so...
Let's just go for it, baby!
I almost want to get the commissary.
But I mean we could just keep going up.
We could just keep going up, I mean...
Let's just, you know what?
Up.
Let's just keep going up.
Oh, this is the one that says...
Use the key.
Leads to a room color of your choice.
Wait...
Will the secret passage go up?
Does the secret passage go up?
I can't tell.
Yes?
No?
Looks like it goes up.
Potentially.
It does look like it, right?
Right here?
I'm trying to get more steps.
But...
The storeroom could be good and it's free, so...
Let's go with the storeroom.
Hey, Minky.
Hello!
Hello?
And a gemmy.
This time it doesn't have the stars on it.
So I feel if I get the four stars...
I have to find the painting with it.
Key to... Oh, here we go.
Can you imagine?
It's just like, I want a red...
Halls?
Green thumb?
What's a gold room?
Oh, that's like the kitchen or the commissary.
I mean, I could just get a hallway.
We could keep going up.
What if I get to the top and I have nothing?
The north is stored in the halls.
Good thing we got another one.
Yeah, they say it's...
Wait, these are new!
Hallway doors are always unlocked.
The aquarium!
Is every color of room.
Wow.
Guys, this is the furthest we've been!
They do say that this is locked, so I might be just screwing myself over a little bit.
Wait, hopefully we get a beat.
I didn't even know you could get nothing.
Ouch.
OK.
This one is locked.
Now we are...
So we can go back to the drawing room.
And unlock over here.
North we go up?
You guys are insane.
You guys...
You guys are insane!
North!
Uh-oh.
Redraw?
Let's just redraw this.
That's what I'm talking about baby.
This is so liminal space.
Hey I'm here!
Let me in!
You can't go in the water.
Well I think it's sealed.
What do we got here?
Guys, I don't have a lot of money.
Guys?
I'm kind of in trouble.
The bedroom?
Let's do the bedroom.
We can kind of...
Oh my gosh!
An apple!
A day keeps the doctor away!
Nice.
Nice, nice, nice.
We can at least farm some...
Some steps here.
I'm going to start looking in between things because apparently...
There's like coins and stuff on the floor.
I should have been doing that earlier but...
I don't know if they only unlock once you...
Once you get the metal detector or not but I don't know.
Oh.
Blue note?
Oh it's just a postcard.
Let's go back to the drawing room.
It's not a dead run yet.
Drafting pool rules.
The draft pool is your deck of potential floor plans.
Each time you draft, three random floor plans are drawn from the draft pool for you to select from.
The odds of drawing a specific floor plan may differ depending on the room.
Some rooms are more rare than others.
Floor plans added to the draft pool are removed at the end of the day unless otherwise stated.
No running.
Okay.
Keep your eyes peeled for some dirt on the floor.
By the way.
And money on the floor.
That was the store room.
I don't really know what to pick here.
Oh yeah we can redraw.
You're right.
Thank you.
I wish there was something that gave us more steps.
But...
Yeah I think I'll do the courtyard because I was thinking that too.
Because it will have...
Our first security door.
Okay coin.
Single coin.
Turn up.
Sorry.
Okay.
It also goes down.
Bless you.
Thank you.
I still haven't gotten the outdoors door on the right side.
I think I want the key instead actually.
Bless you.
Thank you.
You have to go all the way to the right to get those rooms.
Exactly.
You need a kitchen.
But I don't have a lot of money.
I only have 6 coins.
Oh get the breaker.
You can depower the security doors.
Maybe that would be...
Oh yeah I guess that would be better than the security room.
Let's do the nook.
And get a key.
Do the nook and get a key.
And...
Is this locked?
No.
Go to the parlor.
Bless you Puki.
Oh yeah, we can get the A rank meal now.
You're right!
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8!
Let's do the...
Let's do the parlor.
Yeah, we got to ration our steps for real.
It's a coin thing!
Nice!
Oh my gosh, now every time we collect 3 we get an extra.
Give me that.
Let's see what we got here.
Money, money, money.
This box is the...OK.
This box is the blue box.
The box that claims to be black has the gems.
Oh wait.
You!
This says blue?
Yeah.
It's always the blue.
I don't really need the gemmies anymore, but whatever.
Garages.
3 more.
Hold on.
And then we can go back outside.
We can get 3 more keys and then go back outside.
But it would be...
We can go from the den maybe.
Oh it's not powered!
You're right!
It's not powered.
I didn't get the security room.
We were so blinded by going up, but...
We do have another...I can still get the keys.
Guys, I can still get the keys.
And this one was locked and this one was locked.
So let's do that.
See?
We just can't open the garage door.
Kisses.
Will we make it?
1, 2, 3, 4.
It's okay.
Don't worry everybody.
Don't worry.
We are getting 10 more steps.
There is something in here.
A magnifying glass.
Inspect documents of the estate more closely.
Nice.
Have I gone in this room before?
Oh yeah, this is the guest one.
This is the guy who is just like...
Interesting.
Now we go back to the bedroom.
No running.
And we gained 2.
Use?
The bedroom.
Got it.
Oh wait, not keys first.
These all suck.
Oh no.
Guys...
The chapel.
This is a pretty dead run.
Laboratory.
Experimental house features.
This machine requires additional power.
Piped in from the boiler room.
I see.
I typically work over at Sinka Labs but got sent over here for a month to assist more with the new turbine tests.
I think I need some help.
For the past 3 days I have been unable to find the laboratory on the estate.
Today was the first success on that front.
Can anyone tell me if this is typical?
And if so, how do you get any work done?
Finally, someone who has stayed.
Before I arrived I was briefed on the way the doors worked but I must admit I did not expect to be excluded from my new workstation for the first week.
Any tips from my fellow technicians would be appreciated.
Kimberly Thompson.
Yes, Kimberly, finally a normal ass person.
That's a normal ass response.
Eating and cooling curves.
Cooler is unaffected.
Okay.
I don't get it.
I don't want to look at that.
That actually hurts my brain.
Oh no.
Why do I need to look at this?
No.
Is this re...
No thank you.
What does he have to do with it?
What?
Are they related?
Why are they connected?
Laboratory too scary.
This one looks like probably one of those that you have to like, you know, you get just the right amount to get to like that line and all.
To figure out which levers.
That's what I imagine.
Check the computer.
I'm not there yet.
Effective immediately.
Electronic mail can only be accessed via the security terminal.
This is false.
Don't lie to me.
Wait, wasn't there an email that we were going to get?
In the laboratory, you are free to experiment by testing and combining different mechanics to create an original and unique house feature that will last until the end of the day.
Whenever you draw... Oh, next time you eat an apple.
Close ten steps.
Add three aquariums.
Okay, interesting.
That's just a cause and effect thing.
That's kind of fun.
No research log.
Research log will be available the day after an experiment has been performed.
Okay.
Yeah, useless for us today, pretty much.
Well, at least we got to see some of the new rooms, like the laboratory.
Laboratory.
Even though...
Wait, what do you mean by that?
What do you mean by that?
Three?
Oh.
Hold on.
Oh, it's a code.
Okay, H.
Wait.
One, two, H.
Okay, I'm going to try and figure this out.
Oh, cool.
Wait, twelve.
Let's do ten.
Ten was RN, right?
Is it...
Is it... Wait.
It's not to this, because this goes to twelve, or to ten, and this is to twelve.
This is not writing a sentence, I feel.
We'll do eight and twelve.
F.
And E.
Oh, Sheena!
Thanks for the raid!
Hello!
Hello, everybody!
So many crabs.
So cute, thank you!
Raymac, thanks for the gift, and for playing this game.
I'll have to be a really big brain for it, too.
S.
Mugmug, thanks for the gifting!
Mugmurabba, thanks for the five gifted.
Hello, Ducky, thanks for the gifting!
Alright, hold on.
Let me do one.
What does the arrow mean, though?
One, two, three, four, five, six.
Oh!
Okay, it says push!
Push?
Okay, so the first four is push.
Okay, four.
Four, seven.
I can do four, seven.
Push, push!
T.H.
Seven was P.A.
Okay.
K.
Barney, thanks for the five gifted!
T.
Dontcha, thanks for the five gifted!
Thank you, guys!
Push, push.
Um, what am I missing?
Five.
One, two, three, four, five, six, seven.
Seven.
R.E.
I know I should probably just screen cap one of these.
Why did they... Seven also.
Yeah.
I did.
Yeah, well, whatever.
E.U.
Push.
There.
No.
Push three up.
Ah, so nine is probably T.E., I imagine.
Oh!
Why'd they put those two numbers next to each other?
Yeah, T.E.
After.
After nine.
Nine.
Push three up after nine.
That's what it says!
I figured it out!
I could've probably just brute-forced the other one.
I fear...
I fear we could've brute-forced this.
But we don't have the power anyway, so...
What do we do now?
I think we're locked.
Wait, can I make it back to the den?
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9!
No!
Don't tell Sheena, but she was streaming MGS3 before raiding.
That's like my favorite game ever.
That's like my favorite game series ever!
I am out of gear.
A normal amount, probably.
Look at the size of this guy.
There's the little bedrooms.
This is a...
barbecue.
Therapist.
You do?
I had no idea.
Yeah, it's like my most well-kept secret.
Ever.
I'm just that good at, you know...
keeping my mouth shut.
Dang, this could've been the run.
We got so...
Oh wait, I got two more!
Everything
I could've wanted is in here.
Yeah, for the bedroom.
That's right.
Also, that scene was hilarious.
That guy...
I can't bring him up around me.
I become unwell.
I'm already unwell because of him.
So for anybody who came in from the red and doesn't know, this is a roguelike puzzle game.
Our inheritance is in here, apparently.
But...
We have 50 steps a day.
Give or take.
Yeah, I'm eating spicy popcorn because it's all I have.
Is there a limited number of days?
I don't think so.
It didn't mention.
But...
Yeah, you have a limited number of days and...
And...
Hold on.
What was it?
Yeah, there are different rooms that do different things.
You can see all the items in the house.
This affects stuff too.
How do I access the e-mail?
Tells us how to... OK, I'm going to get the security.
No, I cannot.
I was going to say, because there is an e-mail that's supposed to come through.
That will have us... I remember...
I remember, it said...
That...
In the mail room, it was like, oh, an e-mail will come through and it will show you more information about the breaker box.
We need the login password for the computer!
Oh my god.
How do we get that?
Try the boudoir.
Boudoir.
OK.
Sexy lady room.
I imagine this is the same.
What if there is an apple in here?
25.
This run was so bad because we just kept losing steps and kept...
This is the one time I have so many jammies, you know?
Also four.
Damn, Daniel.
The one time I... What is this?
The first time you enter each bedroom with the sleep mask...
Gain 5 steps?
Wait, does that mean all of these rooms too?
Wait, are we so back?
Or is it bedroom?
What was it?
Oh, each bedroom.
OK.
Just kidding everybody.
Just kidding.
Sauna?
Please, please, please let it work for me!
What is that?
What was the key for?
Four!
We literally passed out in the sauna.
We are going to die!
OK.
I am going to end it there though.
Thank you guys for...
For blueprints.
This was so interesting.
It's so... I want to keep playing.
I'm not going to lie.
So, we will continue.
Possibly next week.
Thanks for the stream!
This game is so much fun.
I just want to say your voice sound is super good today.
Hope you're feeling great.
Thanks!
Yeah, my voice has been feeling much better lately.
So I'm very happy about that.
Yeah, I rested it for a bit.
It's getting there.
I actually had to record some stuff today too.
And I was like... I already had asked for an extension for this stuff to record.
So I was really happy about it.
What an interesting game.
Thanks for the fun stream.
Thanks, Hikneet!
Actually, I never heard of this game before today.
It was really fun.
Thank you!
Yeah.
I was really interested because of how much people were hyping it up.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
It just came out though, so maybe you can try.
Again, since it's like a roguelike, everybody's games are going to be kind of different, which is always fun.
And I feel like I didn't write enough notes, maybe.
Everyone's like, I have 10 pages worth of notes.
I have a half page.
And a Microsoft notepad.
You're also using screenshots.
That's true too.
We only did, what, three run-throughs?
I mean, I got to rank nine.
I don't want to toot my own horn or anything, but...
I got to rank nine on my third run.
Yeah.
Lots of progress each run.
Yeah!
We did good.
We did good, everybody.
But yeah, I'm going to go.
And I will see you guys later.
Yeah.
There's only one true prince and that's the Prince of Bel-Air.
In West Philadelphia, born and raised.
I spent my days...
Feeble.
Thank you!
Have a good night!
Have a good day!
Bye bye!
Thanks for watching!
Itterasshai!
Thank you!
Bye bye!